LYNSEY: Pummeled
with tank fire mortar rounds.
Riots for bread.
Women who tried
to commit suicide
by setting
themselves on fire.
Many, many women were
dying in child birth.
I was kidnapped
by Gaddafi's troops.
There was no place to hide.
(applause)
So I was 26 the first time
I went to Afghanistan.
And I had been
living in India at the time.
And I had a roommate
who went to Afghanistan
under the Taliban
and he came back
and he said, "You know,
you are a woman.
You should go to Afghanistan
and photograph women living
under the Taliban,
because no one's doing it."
And he didn't tell me
that photography
was illegal at the time,
that you couldn't photograph
any living thing.
And that there was
no American Embassy,
and that the only
governing body was the Taliban,
which was
ruled by Sharia law.
But I was 26 and I didn't care,
and so, I went.
And I took
some pictures of women.
I kept my cameras in my bag,
and I ran around
to people's homes.
And I went
to the hospitals--
this was
a women's hospital in 2000.
There was no medicine,
very few doctors.
This was a woman in labor.
This is a very typical scene
on the streets of Kabul.
This was the capital
at the time.
There were almost no cars.
Women beggars were
really the only women
you would
ever see on the street.
Any form of entertainment
was illegal.
There was no music,
no television,
and no cell phone.
So, when I would go to
Afghanistan at the time,
I would literally fall off
the face of the planet.
I would have no idea
what was happening
outside of Afghanistan.
This scene happened.
I was out at a refugee camp
because there was
a drought in Herat,
which was
western Afghanistan.
And I was with my driver
and he said,
"Madam, I have to go early,
because my brother
is getting married."
And I said, "Great.
Let's go to your
brother's wedding."
So, he took me in.
I brought one camera,
one lens and I hung out.
And I had been on a street,
like the picture
you had just seen.
And we descended
down these stairs
and the Titanic
was blasting.
And men and women
were dancing together.
And this was all under
the Taliban in secret.
About 9 years later,
National Geographic
assigned me to photograph
women in Afghanistan.
And I spent about 2 years
photographing.
And the changes
that had been made
were astonishing to me.
I had been working
pretty much consistently
in Afghanistan since 2000,
so I went almost every year.
And my last trip
was about 5 months ago.
This is a wedding.
The man on the right
is the father of the groom
and he is a filmmaker
in Afghanistan.
This is a typical scene
of a midwife.
This is
in Badakhshan Province.
And that province
has very few roads.
So, many, many women die
in childbirth in Afghanistan,
mostly because of the
lack of access to hospitals
and doctors.
So, what you see
here is a woman,
a midwife from Merlin,
and she would go out
into very remote villages
and they would make
an announcement at the mosque.
And pregnant women
and women with young children
would come
and meet with her.
And after spending
about two weeks
in Badakhshan Province,
I was driving back to Fayzabad,
which is the capital.
And I notice these two women
on the side of the mountain.
And I said,
"That's strange,
there's no man
with those women."
And anyone who's worked
extensively in Afghanistan
knows that there was always
a man with the women.
So we stop the car
and Dr. Zieba,
who was my translator
and an amazing Afghan woman,
she jumped out
and we ran up the mountain
and she said,
"What's going on?"
And the woman
on the right was in labor,
and her water
had just broken.
And they had rented a car
and her husband's first wife
had died in childbirth.
And he was so determined
to not have a second wife die
in childbirth
that he rented this car,
and they were driving
from their village to Fayzabad,
the capital,
and their car broke down.
And so I said, "Get in my car
and I'll take you
to the hospital."
And they said, "We can't.
We need the permission
of her husband."
And so I said, "Dr. Zieba,
go find the husband."
And fortunately
there was a one road
that led throughout
the whole province.
So, she took our car
and she found
the husband.
They all came in my car,
and she delivered.
Everyone always
asks me if I took--
if I have
pictures of her delivering.
And I stopped
photographing at the point
that I left them,
that I put them in my car,
because I changed the story
as a journalist
and I didn't feel like it
was ethical
to keep photographing.
Many women in Afghanistan
end up in prison
simply for asking for a divorce,
for doing things
that in the west,
we would see
as not justifiable
to end up in prison.
This is Mida Hall.
She was married
at a very young age to a man
who was decades
older than her.
He was handicapped,
so every day her duties
as a wife were to bathe him
and to take care of him
and feed him.
When she was 21,
she asked for a divorce
and she was thrown in prison
by his brothers.
This is a young woman.
Women in Afghanistan
who are unhappy
or who are ashamed,
they don't take a gun
and try and commit suicide
the way that we would try to
or that's more typical
in the west.
They set themselves
on fire.
And many of those
women don't die.
So, I did a series
for The New York Times
on women who tried
to commit suicide
by setting themselves
on fire.
This young woman
had been accused
by her neighbors of stealing.
And she was so ashamed
that she tried
to kill herself.
And she died a few days
after that picture.
With the Americans
in Afghanistan,
one thing they tried
to do was train up
a police force of women.
And this is at a shooting range
outside of Kabul.
Education has really
picked up in Kabul,
that's something
when I first I used to go,
there were secret girl schools
in people's homes,
hidden from the Taliban.
And now you see
women graduating.
This is a women's
boxing team.
This is a woman
in parliament.
They're women in parliament,
sorry.
There are soap operas with women
and women actresses.
This is a soap opera set,
in Kabul.
This is Trina.
She is an actress.
She did soap operas
and she was also in some movies.
So, in 2009 and 2010,
I accompanied the Marines'
female engagement teams,
throughout Helmand Province.
This was a program,
started by the Marines,
to have American women
engage Afghan women,
because
many of the Marines--
all the Marines operating
in Helmand Province were men.
And there was
a whole 50% of the society,
they couldn't--
they couldn't engage.
And they couldn't go
into people's homes.
So, they brought women in.
And they had them
talk to Afghan women,
look at them
for basic medical treatment.
It was
fascinating for me,
because I had been
embedding with the military
for many, many years,
but I was always the only woman.
So, it was the first time
that I was able to be
around women,
to go around and see
how they operate
in this hostile environment.
This is a female
Blackhawk Pilot, Jesse.
And she used to go in
and pick up the injured.
She was working
with the Medevac Team.
This is them, training.
This is
all in Helmand Province:
cleaning their guns,
relaxing at night.
And it was the first time--
You know,
usually when I embed
with the military,
there's no place
for me to sleep.
It's always
this big crisis,
where is the female journalist
gonna sleep.
And so, I finally
was able to sleep
in a normal cot
with a bunch of women,
which was really fun.
And I loved seeing them
still try and do their makeup
and be feminine
even on the front lines.
And we patrolled.
And we were shot at.
This was before 2013,
when women were allowed
on the frontlines.
So, this is all in 2010.
(audience laughing)
I love this picture.
In 2009, I was given
a MacArthur Fellowship
and I wanted to focus on
maternal mortality,
and why women die
in childbirth.
And so--
And it's a body of work
that I have been doing
now for about 5 years.
I went to Sierra Leone,
to photograph
in the Magburaka
government hospital.
It was a place that I knew
many, many women
were dying in childbirth.
I went there one day
and met Mama Sise.
She was a woman
who was pregnant with twins.
She gave birth to the first twin
in the village,
and the second twin
wouldn't come out.
So, she took
a canoe across the river.
There was
an ambulance waiting
for her across the river.
And she drove about
4 hours, across bumpy roads,
to get to the hospital.
And this is when I met her.
She had delivered the first baby
about 24 hours earlier.
She was so scared
and tired to push,
because she was
just exhausted.
And she finally gave birth
and the baby was--
I thought, was still born.
But the nurses spent about
45 minutes
resuscitating the baby.
And they have
very little there.
They don't have
traditional machines
like we do that can--
oxygen and everything.
They're literally
smacking the baby
and trying to bring the baby
back to life.
In that time, Mama Sise
started bleeding.
I thought there was
something wrong,
but I'm not a doctor,
I'm just a photo-journalist.
And so I kept asking,
"Why is she bleeding so much?"
And they were just
mopping up the blood
and saying she's fine.
Finally, I went
to go get the doctor,
and he was in surgery.
When I came back,
her blood pressure was down
to 60 over 40.
They picked her up
and carried her across
the hospital
where the doctor was.
There was one doctor
in the entire province.
And by the time
she got there, she died.
This is her sister
who was also a midwife,
who had arranged
to send her that ambulance
because
she didn't want her to die.
This is the mother finding out
that her daughter
has just died.
And this is in the ambulance.
I went home with her body...
and photographed the rituals
surrounding her death
and her burial.
So, two years later
I got a call from Doctors
Without Borders, MSF.
And they said, "We saw
the story you did.
And since then we've put
five ambulances in Bo province,"
in this one province
next to that province
I'd been in.
And they offer 24 hour
emergency service
to women in Sierra Leone,
in that province,
and they gave
each of the small clinics
in the villages a radio.
So, when a woman
went into the clinic
with complications,
they could call
for an ambulance.
And they said, "With that,
we've reduced
the maternal mortality rate
by 60%."
( indistinct chattering )
( indistinct chattering
continues )
( speaking
in foreign language )
You're almost there.
( Aboriginals singing )
( speaking
in foreign language )
( baby crying )
( Aboriginals singing )
( applause )
In 2011--
It was February of 2011,
and I had watched
the Arab Spring unfold from--
On TV
while I was sitting in Iraq.
And when I was in Afghanistan,
and then, Bahrain.
I was always in the wrong place.
So, I called
The New York Times
and I said,
"I am going to Libya,
whether you want
to send me or not."
So, I went to Libya.
Like most journalists,
I crossed illegally
from Egypt into Eastern Libya.
That was really
the only way to do it,
because any journalist
who wants to cover an uprising,
the government generally
doesn't want
journalists there.
So, you have to sneak in.
When I got there,
it was very euphoric.
People were really celebrating
the uprising.
A parallel government
was being set up.
There were demonstrations.
People were really happy.
They thought Gaddafi
was gonna fall quickly.
They called people
to fight against
Gaddafi's troops,
and they were clearly untrained.
There were doctors,
engineers,
teachers, learning
how to use weapons.
Immigrants were fleeing.
People who had gone to
Libya to work, were trying
to get boats out
of the country.
They felt that the fighting
was imminent.
And in Benghazi,
there was really an
air of tension.
About a week
after I got there,
some rebels started
pushing forward
towards the front line.
And a handful
of photographers--
It's always the
crazy photographers
who go forward.
We started moving forward
with Gaddafi's troops.
We ended up
on the front line.
This is Ra's Lanuf.
What you see in the background
is an oil refinery.
And we followed them,
as cities fell
from Gaddafi's hands
into rebel hands.
They went in,
they would shoot out
pictures of Gaddafi,
go into homes.
The fighting was really
disproportionate.
Gaddafi had a trained military,
and we were with the rebels.
So, this is an example of --
We were on the front line.
It was one road
that sliced through the desert,
from west to east.
One day,
we were on the front line
when a helicopter gunship
came in directly
above us and started spraying
the ground around us with
.50 caliber bullets,
like this big.
They had to fight back
with Kalashnikovs.
Some of the soldiers--
Some of the rebels
were throwing
rocks up into the air.
Many times,
they just turned around
and fled when Gaddafi's
military approached.
We had been
sort of spoiled by being
with the American military,
the Marines in Afghanistan
and Iraq.
And it was very different.
This particular day,
we were being pummeled
with tank fire, mortar rounds.
We would just
follow the front line,
as it pushed back
and forward.
We were really trying to get
a sense of what was happening.
And it was before
the no-fly zone was
put in place.
So, as journalists,
we really wanted to show
what was happening so that--
While the no-fly zone
was being deliberated,
we can provide
a firsthand picture
of what was happening
on the ground.
The rebels were
really getting injured
and killed around us.
The fighting was
very, very intense.
There was no place to hide.
We would be on the front line
and we would hear
the hum of an aircraft.
And you would literally
just hope that the bomb
didn't land on top of you.
Cower in fear.
This particular bomb
landed about 100, 200 feet
from where we were
standing.
And we pushed forward with them,
as they took more ground.
Several days
after that I took this picture,
I was kidnapped by
Gaddafi's troops
with three other journalists
for The New York Times.
So, that was the last picture
in that series.
Luckily, I had a premonition
that something might happen,
so I sent a hard drive out
with a colleague
and said,
"if I get taken,
please send this
to my agency."
And that's how I was able
to salvage all my pictures.
Last year, I wanted to cover
what was happening in Syria.
But my family begged me
not to go into Syria.
So, I started covering
the refugee crisis.
I've made eight trips
to the region: Turkey,
Jordan, Lebanon,
Northern Iraq,
and I did go
once into Syria.
And so, this is
a collection of photos
with the Syrian refugees.
These are refugees streaming
into Northern Iraq.
And this is them
waiting for handouts
in Northern Iraq,
after arriving.
This is a food distribution
in Zaatari,
when there were
riots for bread.
This is a family
arriving in Zaatari
for the first time,
and when they're getting
registered with the
United Nations, in Zaatari.
And a family sleeping outside,
at dawn, in Iraq.
This is a funeral
for a rebel fighter.
And they're cooking.
The body was still in Syria,
but this is the family cooking.
People were
living in caves, in Lebanon.
I went back to these caves
several months ago,
and the families have all been
moved into makeshift camps.
There are no camps in Lebanon,
because
the Lebanese government is--
Does not want
formal camps set up.
This is at a bread distribution,
in Zaatari.
And these are the camps on the
Syrian side of the border.
People were
living in raw sewage.
There were no NGOs
working there except IHH,
a Turkish NGO at the time.
And this is in Syria.
He was a former fighter
and he was living in a school
with his family.
This is outside of
a smuggler's village in Turkey.
I was waiting to try
and photograph
the exodus of refugees
coming out of Syria.
And it's a picture
that's very, very difficult
to get as a photographer now,
because all of the neighboring
countries have really
shut down their borders.
So, I stood outside
of the smuggler's village,
because I knew
that they were crossing there.
And every hour or so,
someone would come up
to me and say,
"Get out of here,
we're gonna kill you."
And one guy came up
to me and he said,
"I'm gonna
go get my knife."
Another guy
came up to me and said,
"Just wait until dark,
because when dark comes,
you'll see all the refugees."
So, I put my cameras in my bag
and I waited.
And, of course, at dark
they all started streaming out.
This is
a family living in a camp
across from a formal camp,
in Turkey.
They were literally
living under the trees.
And this is
that same camp.
I just want to show you
a few on-assignment pictures,
because I think it's funny.
This was me in 2001,
in Pakistan.
This is me,
in Fallujah.
Crossing illegally into Darfur,
to cover the war in Darfur.
We had to walk
for three kilometers,
most of that through wadis.
This is--
We had lived on the
back of this pickup truck
for five days, driving through
the desert in Darfur.
This is the Korangal Valley,
in Afghanistan.
I was embedded
with the 173rd.
That's me and my colleague,
in Afghanistan.
That's me
and that same colleague.
( laughter )
Sort of like
being an actor.
And this is us hiding
in that silo, in Libya,
on the front line.
And this is us
That's me with Tyler Hicks.
And we were taken together.
That's Gary Cosgrove
and Nikki Sobecki.
And this is an example of
where we stay typically,
in Libya, on the front line.
People-- Libyans would
just open their homes
to journalists
who were there.
And for example,
in this particular house,
there were
17 journalists sleeping.
And every night ,
we got a knock on the door
at about 6:00, and it was
a 10-year-old Libyan boy.
He would come
with a giant tray of food
and just set it down and leave.
And so, the women who were
still in the village would
cook for us every night.
And on the upper right
is Anthony Shadid.
He is a colleague,
and he died in Syria last year
of an asthma attack.
And that's it.
( applause )